-What an amazing day.
We have a new president,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have the first female,
first black,
first Asian-American
Vice President.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just thought the whole thing
was so great.
It was hard not to get emotional
just watching that whole thing.
It was perfectly done.
Every performance was top-notch
and everything crushed.
Then Amanda Gorman
just comes out of nowhere.
I mean, I was like, "What?"
And just crushes --
steals the show from what's
already a great show, I thought.
and I just thought today
was just --
Oh, it was just --
it was a beautiful thing.
But another big deal today --
today is actually
Questlove's 50th birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
5-0.
♪ Da, da da, da dee dee ♪
Did you think when everyone
was cheering about you
when they opened up the windows
in New York City this morning?
-I thought it was about me.
-Of course, yeah.
-Well, we, uh --
Tariq would like to give you
a gift, a birthday present,
if you don't mind, and would
like to do it right now.
-Well, I wanted to give you
a thoughtful gift
because this is a -- you know,
it's a milestone birthday,
and I know mine
is coming up soon, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-No, so I thought, you know,
what could sort of speak
to your love for music
and, you know, be a nod
to The Roots and I was thinking
question marks
and the heart pins
that you wear all the time.
And I said, "If I were gonna
design a logo for you,
what would it be?"
And I was talking
with my sister, Prit,
who is a jewelry designer,
and she said, "Well, you know,
there's something
that kind of already exists,
you know, that speaks to all
those different things."
And I was -- You know,
I'd already been thinking about
getting a sankofa tattoo.
'Cause I was like, if I'm gonna
get a facial tattoo,
like, what is it gonna be?"
So I was gonna get this bird
on my face that is,
like, the sankofa,
which is a word
from the language
in Ghana, West Africa,
that speaks to appreciating
just your roots.
"Sankofa" means
"Go back and get it."
So, normally,
when you see an emblem
like the symbol for sankofa,
it's a bird
with his feet facing forward,
and his head is facing its back
and it's holding a delicate egg,
like, in its mouth.
So I'm gonna
get that on my cheek.
So I didn't get that for you,
but I realized the other --
the other --
the other symbol for sankofa
is a stylized heart shape.
So I was like,
"Wow. What could I do?"
I designed this heart-shaped
lapel pin for you
that I want to present you with.
And it's encrusted in rubies
with a yellow diamond.
Just take that pouch off
the top there.
-Oh, I can't have this part?
Okay.
-My birthday was in September,
by the way.
[ Laughter ]
-But you didn't turn 50.
-Yeah.
That's correct.
-Oh, snap.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
Oh, this is real?
-Yeah.
-Look at that thing.
-Man!
-Well, hold it --
Hold it like the heart.
-Okay, yes.
-There you go.
-Oh, man, thank you.
-And if you look at it on the
back, there's an inscription.
It says, "From organics
to endgame and beyond.
Brotherly love."
-Aww.
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
-Happy birthday.
-Thank you.
Man...
[ Laughter ]
-Aw, come on.
We never do this,
like, surprise anyone.
-I know! I was, like, waiting
for a cake fight or something.
I'm like,
"Oh, this is real! Okay."
-No.
-Dude, that is so thoughtful.
-Thank you.
-That's amazing, man.
-Yeah.
-I didn't --
You were thinking about
getting a face tattoo?
-Yeah, I'm still gonna get it.
You know, like, the bird
and he's reaching back
and the egg, you know.
Probably right around here
somewhere.
I don't want the beard
to cover it up.
-Yeah. Wow.
-Yeah.
-You should do it too, Jimmy.
-No, I --
-I mean, you hang out with
Post Malone all the time.
-I know.
-You guys can --
-Right now, you know how much
hair and makeup
I have to go through
to cover my face tattoos?
So no one knows?
[ Laughter ]
Questlove, I wanted
to give you a present, as well,
if I could.
Not a big thing, but it's cool.
But I want --
Can we give it to Quest?
-Wow. This --
-Not saying.
But my sister's
a jewelry designer, and, uh...
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no.
All right. So the card --
What does the card say?
-This says 50.
-Okay, now you open the box.
-Okay.
♪♪
And do you know what it is?
-No.
-What?
This is Morris Day's mirror?
-Dude.
-What?!
-Dude, I called --
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man, yo --
Dude,
that's Morris Day's mirror.
-Wow.
-From "Purple Rain"?
-Yeah. Dude,
from Morris Day and the Time.
So I got in touch
with Morris Day.
I got in touch with his --
with his manager, his assistant,
and I said, "Look," I said,
"I got an idea for Quest
for his birthday."
I go, "He's turning 50.
What can I get this guy
who has everything?"
I go, "He would flip out
to get this."
So and I said, I go,
"Look, he will cherish it
more than a museum will."
I go, "Just anything you ever
used in a show or anything,
he would love it."
And he texted me back.
And he texted me back,
"Ask Jerome."
-Wow.
Wow.
-Because you know Jerome
is like, "Jerome"!
-Yeah.
-And then Jerome comes out,
he goes,
"Let me work on something."
Dude, so I had it for, like,
three days, and I'm like,
"This is 50, 'cause you are
looking into your --
That's what 50 looks like."
-Guys, I'm speechless, really.
-Wow.
-Wow. This is amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at that.
-Yo, I mean, you know...
But listen, listen,
since we're talking about gifts,
are those Christian Dior Jordans
you got on?
-Yeah, I was gonna say.
-I don't really know.
Are they?
-Wow!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Wow.
-Are they good, man?
-I mean, you know...
-Yeah, it's cool.
-Just kind of fun.
-I like J's, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's
not your birthday yet, you know?
-Well, it was in October.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyways, happy birthday,
Questlove!
Come on.
-Oh, man.
-We love you, buddy.
Here's to many, many, many more.